no solo
[Música]
muy buenos días pues es un gusto
participar en tdt women y poder
platicarles sobre el maravilloso mundo
de la inclusión
yo no tengo discapacidad y no empecé en
estos temas porque algún familiar tenga
discapacidad yo comencé por el ejemplo
de mis papás en trabajar por la
inclusión sobre todo en actividades de
recreación al aire libre para personas
con discapacidad
en 1996 mis papás inician con una
empresa familiar el campamento de las
cría y hemos trabajado durante 25 años
realizando campamentos de aventura
inclusivos hemos tenido la oportunidad
de poder atender a más de 25 mil
personas con discapacidad de todos los
tipos de discapacidad nosotros empezamos
con los campamentos inclusivos ya que
cuando empezó la empresa conocimos a
personas con discapacidad que nos
pidieron hacer los eventos inclusivos y
desde entonces son buenos amigos y
excelentes asesores posteriormente creó
mi propia empresa una agencia de viajes
inclusiva el objetivo de la agencia es
encontrar todas las soluciones de
accesibilidad eliminar las barreras para
que ninguna persona sea discriminada en
la actividad turística
cuando me preguntan por qué tu empresa
es inclusiva creo que la pregunta
debería de ser y que yo se las pudiera
preguntar a ellos porque sus empresas no
son inclusivas
actualmente he tenido la oportunidad de
poder impartir más de 30 conferencias en
diferentes países de manera presencial y
más de 100 webinars y ahora con el tema
de la pandemia platicando y aportando a
todos los empresarios del sector turismo
para que cada vez seamos más de empresas
turísticas inclusivas sin embargo
después de un tiempo nos dimos cuenta en
la empresa que no es sólo cuestión de
buena actitud sino es también cuestión
de mucho conocimiento les voy a poner un
ejemplo
entre nuestros amigos ciegos es muy
común decir el secuestro del ciego a qué
nos referimos a que una persona con
discapacidad visual puede estar en una
esquina esperando el camión esperando
algún amigo y de repente alguien llega
lo toma del brazo y lo cruza la calle
sin preguntarle si quería cruzar
por lo tanto hay que recordar que
siempre que veas a una persona con
discapacidad lo recomendable es
acercarte presentarte preguntarle si
requiere ayuda y si te contesta que sí
preguntarle cómo le podemos apoyar
por cierto yo les pregunto a mis amigos
ciegos y qué le dices a la gente cuando
te cruzaron de calle y me dicen nada es
pero ahorita viene otra persona y me
regresa otra vez así como este ejemplo
de los ciegos pasa también muy común con
las personas usuarias de silla de ruedas
que están afuera de una iglesia de una
escuela de un museo llega una persona y
toma la astilla y los empuja hacia
dentro del recinto sin preguntarle si
querían entrar por favor nunca
secuestren a nadie de hecho pero nunca
tomen del brazo a una persona ciega
nunca empujen una silla de ruedas sin
preguntarles antes
y
nosotros estamos actualmente trabajando
en el turismo inclusivo ya que no
podemos quedarnos de brazos cruzados
cuando una de mis mejores amigas no
puede entrar a un restaurant porque el
lugar no está accesible
yo creo que necesitamos todos poner
nuestro granito de arena y no hay que
pensar en cosas tan complicadas
el hecho de no tirar un chicle al piso o
de levantar las heces de nuestro perro
cuando lo sacamos a pasear son pequeños
detalles de inclusión ya que este chicle
o estas heces se quedan pegadas en la
llanta de la silla de ruedas en el
bastón de las personas ciegas o en el
bastón de las personas con discapacidad
motriz hay que hacer pequeñas acciones
como no dejar nuestra puerta de nuestra
cochera abierta o cuando ponemos el
carro sobre la banqueta esas son las
barreras que debemos eliminar
recuerda que a mayor accesibilidad hay
menos discapacidad
una discapacidad es la suma de una
persona que tiene una diversidad
funcional más el entorno y en este
entorno nos referimos a todas las
barreras arquitectónicas de conocimiento
actitudinales etcétera hay que empezar a
eliminar todas estas barreras
algunas de las enseñanzas después de 25
años de haberme dedicado de manera
laboral como activista pero sobre todo
porque tengo muchos amigos con
discapacidad a los cuales les agradezco
su amistad y todos los aprendizajes
y pues he aprendido de las personas con
discapacidad que debemos aceptarnos como
somos amarnos y sentirnos orgullosos de
quiénes somos también les platico que he
reído hasta que me ha dolido la panza
escuchando las anécdotas de mis amigos
con discapacidad visual escuchar cuando
le echaron una cucharada de jabón en
lugar de sal a la sopa cuando se lavaron
los dientes con silicón y muchas
historias más y poder reírnos de todo lo
que nos pasa de mis amigos ciegos he
aprendido a que necesitamos conocer a
las personas por lo que son y no por
cómo nos vestimos por si utilizar ropa
de marca por si ya te salió una cana
simplemente conocer a la persona y poder
ser amigo de ellos y para mí es un gran
honor el poder prestarles mis ojos para
poder describir un paisaje como ahorita
hay una imagen en la cual estamos un
grupo de personas ciegas en las cascadas
de tamasopo de mis amigos sordos he
aprendido que no necesitas decir una
sola palabra para transmitir muchísimas
cosas he aprendido que cuando se trata
de un chisme los oyentes podemos
aprender muchas señas en muy corto
tiempo les quiero agradecer a mis amigos
sordos por haberme enseñado la lengua de
señas mexicana de mis amigos con
discapacidad intelectual he aprendido a
que no deberíamos preocuparnos por el
qué dirán deberíamos disfrutar de la
vida deberíamos de poder reír gritar
saltar sin que nos preocupe si alguien
nos está viendo de mis amigos con
discapacidad psicosocial he aprendido
que la barrera más difícil de romper es
la actitud inal estas barreras sociales
que no se ven pero que no nos dejan
avanzar de mis amigos con discapacidad
motriz he aprendido a que no se
necesitan tener piernas para ser el
mejor atleta he aprendido que una un
hueco de 5 centímetros puede ser una
gran barrera para una persona con
discapacidad motriz y que para muchos de
nosotros cuando vamos al baño es algo
tan normal y que no pensamos en esto
mientras que para un usuario de silla de
ruedas su día depende de en qué lugar va
a poder ir al baño
para muchas personas consideran que la
discapacidad es un tema ajeno a nosotros
no tenemos familiares con discapacidad
sin embargo nadie estamos exentos de
adquirir algún tipo de discapacidad y
les tengo una noticia todos vamos hacia
allá a partir de los 60 años tenemos un
60 por ciento de probabilidades de
adquirir algún tipo de discapacidad por
lo tanto trabajar en accesibilidad es
trabajar en nosotros mismos recuerda que
las personas con discapacidad no buscan
caridad solo exigen sus derechos
definitivamente me dedico a esto por la
satisfacción de poder escuchar cosas
como siempre haya querido entrar al mar
nunca me imaginé que pudiera realizar
esto es la primera vez que viajo de
manera digna y no es tan complicado
muchas veces para un usuario de silla de
ruedas lo único que quiere es poderse
sentar en el pasto para un amigo con
discapacidad severa lo único que quiere
es volverse a tomar un frappuccino para
una persona con discapacidad visual lo
que deseas poderse apostar sobre las
hojas secas abajo de un árbol he tenido
la gran oportunidad de poder atender a
personas en etapa terminal y que sus
familiares y la persona de la asociación
lo único que nos pide es volver a ver
sonreír a la persona y entonces una
sonrisa se vuelve lo más importante y lo
más difícil de lograr
he atendido a personas con depresión
profunda y es un gusto saber que a
través de un viaje le podemos cambiar la
vida a una persona es por eso que me
dedico al turismo inclusivo porque a
través de los viajes hemos logrado
cambiar a diferentes personas que tenían
un concepto de llegar incluso al
suicidio y a través de los viajes hemos
logrado cosas súper importantes y para
cerrar el día de hoy hemos abierto la
revista iberoamericana de turismo
inclusivo el observatorio iberoamericano
de turismo inclusivo y el instituto
iberoamericano de turismo inclusivo para
seguir sumando y esperamos que muchas
empresas más también se sumen nada sobre
nosotros y nosotros muchas gracias
[Música]